dix nations au lendemain de la
validation par le conseil
constitutionnel du pass vaccinale il
entrera en vigueur dès lundi il
remplacera le placent sanitaires pour
accéder à de nombreux lieux publics
comme les bars restaurants ou encore les
cinémas avec son entrée en vigueur des
restrictions vont d'ailleurs être allégé
à partir de 2 février on en parle tout
de suite avec alain fontaine président
de l'association française des maîtres
restaurateurs et avec mathieu receipts
les professeurs des écoles et secrétaire
de snudi fo de moselle
messieurs bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
cet après midi sur rt france pour parler
de cette mise en oeuvre du pacte
vaccinale alain fontaine je me tourne
vers vous pour commencer comment est-ce
que vous abordez vous l'entrée en
vigueur de ce pass vaccinale dès lundi
dans les restaurants
l'entrée l'entrée du passage ça va rien
changer pour nous puisque on demandait
le pass sanitaires la première chose
qu'il faut dire c'est que l'on sort par
joueur quand il faut faire tout ça parce
que on demande à nos employés de le
faire aussi et ce qui est le plus
embêtant par rapport à ce bal passelac
site se base elle était devenue une
passe vaccinale c'est évidemment la
possibilité demande de demander la carte
d'identité quand il ya suspicion
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le monde
suspicion ça s'arrête tout ça donc si
vous laissez ces des contraintes
supplémentaires pour une activité qui
n'est autre qu'un symbole du de l'art de
vivre français et je ne suis pas sûr que
s'il ya fraude aux passes ça se passe
dans les restaurants ou mou depuis qu'on
a deux passes sanitaire à par un pasteur
on va présenter où j'avais une personne
d'une trentaine ou quarantaine d'années
devant moi et qu'ils avaient un poste à
l'inter où il était né en 1935 donc
évidemment je vraiment c'est le seul
incident que j'ai eu et donc la
suspicion va s'arrêter là mais les
restaurateurs les pardonnez-moi lectorat
teurs ils sont prêts aujourd'hui à faire
des contrôles d'identité comme des
policiers finalement où certains vont
s'y refuse et
c'est clair que ça va pas se passer
facilement
d'après ce que j'entends d'après ce que
j'entends ça va se faire vraiment au cas
par cas vraiment par rapport à l'âge
mais c'est pas c'est pas naturel chez
nous de le faire comprendre bien donc ça
va se faire de façon extrêmement rare ça
veut pas dire qu'on est contre le pass
axel vous passez inter ça veut juste
dire qu'il ya une marche peut-être à pas
franchir n'oublions pas qu'on ait un
million de à travailler dans la
restauration
et il y en a 400 milles qui sont à
l'accueil vous rendez compte qu'elle
cent mille personnes là qui on donne des
pouvoirs extraordinaires et quand je dis
extraordinaire je prends bien le mot
dans son terme cl c'est pas du tout
ordinaire pour nous de faire cela donc
voilà ça va ça va simoni alors à vos
côtés mathieu ris je le disais
professeurs des écoles peu de
changements finalement majeur pour les
écoles 1 dès lundi avec le pass
vaccinale puisque vous n'êtes pas
concernés néanmoins la perspective d'un
allongement du protocole à l'école après
les vacances de février on le sait un
protocole louera notamment avec les
tests à répétition pour les élèves cet
allégement il arrive trop tôt il arrive
trop tard
j'écoutais ils se trouveront tout en
décalage avec la situation sanitaire je
rappelle que les enseignants sont en
grève et under massivement 13 janvier
que la mobilisation se poursuit avec
avec encore des temps forts cette
semaine le 20 janvier et puis une grosse
mobilisation à nouveau le 27
encore une fois c'est une véritable
provocation du gouvernement on était en
grève entre autres pour des raisons de
poids des raisons sanitaires le 13
c'était pas les salles il y avait
également la question des salaires était
armé mais on demande de plus de sécurité
sur notre lieu de travail et puis où il
on ne répond par un nouvel allègement
protocole à venir alors qu'on est à un
des fils de contamination confirmés
atteints justement il ya eu ces
promesses du gouvernement qui ont été
faites des recrutements et des masques
ffp2 aussi on en est où aujourd'hui vous
les avez ces masques alors non ça fait
maintenant d'être dix jours sur les
masques il est toujours rien alors ça
commence à arriver au compte gouttes ce
jeu j'ai vu par exemple que certains à
part dans certains endroits il était
arrivé et y arriver hier des masques de
chantier
comprend pas comment est ce qu'on va
faire comment on va faire classe avec
des marques de chantier des masques ffp2
quand est ce qui a été annoncé ces 5
millions de masques pour un million
d'enseignants donc je vous laisse conter
ça fait cinq masques par personne on va
pas aller bien loin avec ça et puis
quand on nous annonce le protocole qui
va être allégé on est en train d'essayer
de comprendre qu'il faut qu'il faut lire
entre les lignes et puis que finalement
on va alléger le protocole avant même
qu'on ait réussi à nous fournir les
masques donc à nouveau tour de passe
passe du gouvernement sur les
contractuels alors le ministère continue
d'annoncer des recrutements massifs de
contractuels sauf qu'en face il ya pas
de candidat donc le ministre pour
annoncer que l'on recrute un million ça
resterait que des paroles parce que je
n'y a pas de candidat en face au
contraire il ya des démissions qui
s'accumulent moi je prends dans le cas
de mon département par exemple on est
déjà 20 des missions d'enseignants
depuis là depuis la dernière rentrée
voilà je crois que je crois que c'est
des choses qu'il faut en temps et il se
passe la même chose dans les hôpitaux
j'entendais ça tout à l'heure dans votre
introduction on en est là aussi dans les
écoles aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
l'abandon du port du masque pour les
élèves par exemple pour vous c'est pas
ça doit pas être d'actualité aujourd'hui
alors là dessus syndicalement on n'a pas
de position là dessus nous ce qu'on
demande c'est le bleu port du masque des
élèves on n'a pas de position les
représentants des personnels enseignants
ce qu'on demande c'est d'être protégé
nous mêmes c'est que les enseignants et
ash et droit des masques ffp2 ils sont
en contact on le redit mais on a
toujours encore des masques en tissu les
investir availles à 20 cm parfois des
élèves parce que ces élèves en situation
de handicap il faut le contact physique
la proximité physique en maternelle les
élèves n'ont pas de menace donc ce qu'on
demande c'est que les personnels sa
protégée
moi je compare souvent que l'allemagne
parce que je je je suis à côté de
l'allemagne est dans mon département il
a la classe et gérés de manière
totalement différente avec un dépistage
systématique de tous les élèves tous les
personnels deux fois par semaine des
capteurs de co2 des purificateurs d'air
qui sont déjà en place et il les masques
ffp2 dont ils demandent les enseignants
que les enseignants déjà à leur
disposition depuis octobre 2020 et nous
un an et demi plus tard il ya toujours
rien
donc voilà le ministre a apporté
quelques réponses et nous ajouter
quelques miettes à la tête la semaine
dernière pour l'instant les quelques
miettes n'ont même pas n'ont même pas
été concrétisées enfin je vous assure
que la colère est en train de remonter
et le 27 janvier on pense qu'on va nous
être en force dans la rue à la fin tu es
longtemps le lay la colère de mathieu
ris
avec l'arrivée de ce pass vaccinale
finalement vous craignez une baisse de
fréquentation ou au contraire finalement
bien retour davantage à la vie normale
clairement clairement on redoute en
premier une baisse de fréquentation mais
vous savez on sera pas pire que ce qu'on
vit depuis maintenant le mois de
décembre il a poussé du variant au micro
c'est c'est très très dur on est en
france entre 30 entre maintenant et -70%
alors pour autant et heureusement le
gouvernement nous suit nous aide
financièrement on est effectivement
parmi les pays européens et au monde les
mieux lotis mais aussi nous sommes un
sam un symbole de l'art de vivre à la
française donc c'est pour ça qu'on nous
aide aussi
mais oui on redoute on redoute bien
évidemment une baisse de fréquentation
dans les premiers jours nous ce qu'il
nous faut c'est le retour à la normale
rapidement alors ça semble s'alléger oui
je comprends les inquiétudes j'ai
moi-même trois enfants dont jean les
deux que j'ai gardé toute la semaine
dernière puisque leur leur maîtresse
était malade donc ça désorganise aussi
je participe à ce que disait mathieu ça
désorganise aussi les entreprises donc
il va falloir qu'il y ait une cohérence
entre la réouverture des commerces de
façon pleine avec la possibilité de deux
bouts et tout et en même temps
effectivement que tout le monde puisse
faire son travail de l'hôpital aux
écoles parce que si dans les écoles il
ya des problèmes ça va rejaillir sur les
entreprises et donc nous le télétravail
plus là désinv les entreprises à cause
des absences d'école justifier qu vie
des autres eh bien ça pose des problèmes
évidemment ça ne pose de problème donc
il faut que tout soit cohérent et que
tout ça les gens même temps mathieu rice
le mot de la fin vous comprenez
finalement cette nécessité pour alain
fontaine est bien de débloquer un petit
peu aussi les écoles pour que l'économie
générale fonctionne alors oui enfin moi
je tiens à rappeler qu'on est pas du
tout pour la fermeture des écoles nous
serons nous risquons demande depuis un
an et demi c'est qu'on nous permette de
faire notre travail correctement et je
rebondis sur ce qu'il a dit aujourd'hui
on en est au même stade on peut pas
faire notre travail correctement et et
on a l'impression qu'à l'image de ce qui
se passe dans l'hôpital en fait l'état
est en train le gouvernement est en
train de saboter le l'hôpital commis sa
botte l'école et pour accélérer en fait
là l'étape suivante qui va être la
privatisation et on est en train
d'essayer de faire comprendre aux gens
que le service public n'est plus capable
de fonctionner parce qu'on fait en sorte
qu'elles ne fonctionnent plus et l'épi
de décines justifier que la
privatisation va ça va s'accélérer dans
les mois à venir merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté de répondre et
d'échangés en direction rt france cet
après-midi merci alain fontaine
président de l'association française des
maîtres restaurateurs
merci maturi ce professeur des écoles
secrétaire du snudi fo de moselle